[Musique]
à l'étranger au liban il ya encore eu
des combats beyrouth sur la ligne de
démarcation et puis surtout il ya cette
menace du jihad islamique
une menace qui concerne les otages
occidentaux détenus par cette
organisation
parmi eux il y à des français le djihad
islamique exige la libération de ses
propres militants emprisonnés au koweït
en échange justement de ces otages
un avertissement qui a été adressée aux
principaux journaux libanais philippe
lefait c'est par cette lettre envoyée
aux journaux libanais qu'est venu
l'ultimatum
on peut y lire nous n'attendrons pas
longtemps nous terroriseront la france
et l'amérique avec ses six photos
publiées ce matin à beyrouth
le djihad islamique authentifie son
avertissement parmi ces six occidentaux
il y a deux diplomates français marcel
fontaine chargé du protocole et marcel
carton vice-consul ils ont été enlevés
près d'ici le 22 mars dernier par les
brigades de khaybar origines extrémistes
chi dissidents rattachement supposé
téhéran la france avait beaucoup compté
pour leur libération sur la visite en
iran du leader de la communauté chiite
libanaise
apparemment en vain les deux français
font désormais l'objet d'un chantage
globale du jihad islamique
il intervient alors qu'à paris on évoque
beaucoup ces temps ci le liban extension
du rôle des soldats français au sud
neutralisation autant d'idées qui ne
plaisent pas forcément au pays notamment
la syrie ou le jihad à ses antennes pour
ces six hommes devenus monnaie des
changes une détention de près de 60
jours
dans ce contexte extrêmement dangereux
vous l'avez vu deux français viennent de
disparaître il s'agit d'un chercheur du
centre d'études du moyen-orient arrivée
à l'aéroport de beyrouth mercredi après
midi en compagnie d'un journaliste de
l'événement du jeudi jean paul kauffmann
aussitôt débarqué les deux hommes ont
pris en voiture la route vers le centre
ville
la suite c'est le rédacteur en chef du
magazine l'événement du jeudi albert du
roy qui la raconte à daniel leconte jean
paul kauffmann donc l'envoyé spécial de
l'événement et
elle saura qui est un chercheur du cnrs
qui connaît très bien le liban ont pris
ensemble à l'aéroport de beyrouth à taxi
un témoin qui a donné son témoignage un
journal libanais les a vus arrêter un
barrage à hauteur des camps de sabra et
chatila qui sont l'objet actuellement de
combat entre chiites et palestiniens
depuis on n'a plus aucune nouvelle
à partir de ce moment là commencent les
hypothèses alors actuellement il ya deux
hypothèses qui sont formulées et par le
quai d'orsay et donc par nous première
hypothèse est pris dans les combats ils
se sont cachés et ils ne peuvent pas ils
trois jours
je veux donner de leurs nouvelles
deuxième hypothèse ils ont été enlevés
par un mouvement par un groupuscule tout
à fait indéterminée puisque aucune
revendication n'a été formulée
l'ambassade de france à beyrouth a pris
contact avec les principaux mouvements
de l'hiver obédience tous ont démenti
avoir procédé à l'enlèvement tous l'ont
condamné il ya tellement de groupes
incontrôlés à beyrouth actuellement que
tout est possible
le problème c'est que actuellement et le
gouvernement français et nous mêmes on
ne sait pas très bien ce qu'on peut
faire dans la mesure où la situation à
beyrouth et d'une confusion extrême
on ne sait même pas à qui s'adresser
pour essayer la voix mais noël
deux semaines après la disparition
mystérieuse d'un journaliste à beyrouth
jean paul kauffmann et d'un chercheur
michel seurat on vient enfin d'obtenir
indirectement de leurs nouvelles des
nouvelles rassurantes puisque on affirme
qu'ils sont en bonne santé mais on ne
sait toujours pas exactement qui les
retient prisonnier à paris le comité de
soutien qui s'est formée la semaine
dernière multiplie les initiatives
emilie raffoul depuis quinze jours la
famille et les amis de jean paul
kauffmann sont sans nouvelles du
journaliste français enlevé à beyrouth
15 jours qu'il a disparu en compagnie du
chercheur michel sort en quinze jours
d'inquiétudes et de supputations
le jihad islamique a revendiqué cet
enlèvement mais jusqu'à ce jour n'a
fourni aucune preuve de cette détention
depuis sa création vendredi dernier le
comité de soutien a déjà reçu des
milliers de signatures
téléphone en signe de solidarité et cet
après midi la première petite lueur
d'espoir aujourd'hui il ya une chose
extraordinaire qui s'est passé nous
étions sans nouvelles depuis quelques
jours sauf eu une vague revendications
du jihad islamique il ya un bijou
absolument sans nouvelles et on retombe
dans l'angoissé
brusquement l'ambassadeur du liban en
france ce midi sur rmc est vrai de monte
carlo a dit - je sais qu'ils sont
vivants
je sais qu'ils sont bien traités je ne
sais pas où ils sont mais le
gouvernement libanais va mal et les
négociations avec le gouvernement vous
avez pris des contacts
oui gouvernement et des comptages je
suis en contact très régulièrement avec
le 1010 affaires étrangères j'ai demandé
je pense obtenir un rendez vous avec
monsieur le président la république ils
se disent s'intéresser personnellement à
faire mais j'ai déjà été reçus à l'isi
pour cela la négociation s'avère
difficile pour une raison en moins qui
détient les deux français
en effet plusieurs groupes agissent le
label du jihad islamique
il reproche à la france son soutien à
l'irak tuant sa guerre contre l'iran
mais plus précisément on ignore ce que
les ravisseurs souhaite obtenir en
échange de la libération des deux
français
nous allons passer à l'étranger mais
c'est à la frontière de l'étranger et de
l'intérieur car ce qu'a dit shimon peres
le premier ministre d'israël est
important puisque en effet il a annoncé
que d'ici une dizaine de jours à peu
près la totalité des prisonniers chiites
libanais qui se trouve à la prison
d'athlètes devrait être libérée c'est
donc une lueur d'espoir pour les otages
français tels que jean paul kauffmann
michel seurat marcel carton et marcel
fontaine
c'est dans cette ancienne prison
forteresse date lite au sud de haïfa que
sont détenus les derniers prisonniers
chiites
capturé par l'armée israélienne au cours
d'opérations de ratissage au sud liban
ces prisonniers étaient devenus monnaie
d échange des otages du boeing de la tbw
a à plusieurs reprises israël avait
libéré par petits groupes
près de 800 shit year shimon peres le
premier ministre israélien a annoncé la
libération totale des derniers détenus
d'atlit le dernier chiites datent lite
seront il relâchait parle quelques jours
la semaine des jo et de fait cette
libération de la centaine de chiites
emprisonné encore apte lite pourrait
débloquer la situation à propos des
otages encore détenus au liban et
surtout la libération peut être des
quatre français jean paul kauffmann
michel seurat marcel fontaine et marcel
carton car nabih berri le leader chiite
a toujours posé comme conditions à la
libération de ces otages la remise en
liberté de tous les détenus
un espoir que partage mme adam kaufman à
cette promesse qui nous étaient faites
pour jean paul et michel c'était après
la libération des otages était w à les
ravisseurs ont dit on libérera kaufmann
et sera quand le dernier prisonnier dati
tu sortiras et cette promesse n'a été
encore répété la semaine dernière j'ai
vu très longuement le docteur béraud qui
était de passage en france et qui le
second du mouvement amal et qui m'a dit
à chaque fois que nous avons contacté un
ravisseur à chaque fois ils nous disent
kaufmann et sera sortir on a vu les
derniers prisonniers à tiques
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes plein
d'espoir gestion sommes pleins d'espoir
on a toujours dit qu'on voulait pas si
vrai ce marchandage d'otages mais malgré
tout c'était notre espoir le plus proche
c'est en tout cas celui là et si ça ne
se fait pas c'est que je crois qu'il
faut on peut plus avoir confiance du
tout dans ce que disent et les
ravisseurs du mouvement amal
faire preuve d'optimisme à propos des
otages français du liban
c'est allé trop vite en besogne
lorsqu'il s'agit de la vie de quatre
hommes détenus pour certains depuis huit
mois maintenant mais tout de même ce
soir pour la première fois il apparaît
que la négociation s'est vraiment engagé
on commence à savoir ce que veulent les
ravisseurs en échange leurs otages c'est
peu mais c'est déjà un point de repère
bueno alba alors le malade c'est
monsieur carton si marcel quart-temps
avec le retour du docteur rade de
beyrouth
on a bien plus que des nouvelles
rassurantes sur l'état de santé des
otages
et si le docteur rad a pu se dire très
optimiste quant à leur sort
c'est vraisemblablement que sa mission
lui semble fructueuse
relayant les démarches des familles ici
les comités kaufman a trahi les
émissaires français sont semble-t-il en
mesure d'apporter des éléments de
réponse à trois questions qui sont
exactement les ravisseurs que veulent
t'ils précisément comment résoudre la
faire à la question que veulent les
ravisseurs de réponse possible d'abord
le remboursement de tout ou partie d'un
investissement d'un milliard de dollars
décidée par le shah en 1975 dans le
consortium nucléaire euros d'isf
personne n'écarte pas la possibilité
qu'il s'agisse de l'une des conditions
posées à téhéran pour la libération des
otages initiatives individuelles dans ce
sens un député français de la majorité
monsieur d'aillet se rendra à téhéran
avec des députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition pour tenter une ébauche de
normalisation des relations franco
iraniennes
une autre condition pourrait être la
libération des auteurs iranien d'un
attentat contre l'ancien premier
ministre chapour bakhtiar c'était à de
paris le 18 juillet 1981 ils ont été
condamnés par la justice et sont
toujours détenus en france
monsieur bakhtiar a été sorti indemne de
cette action qui avait provoqué la mort
de deux autres personnes
la négociation semble donc passer par
l'iran à tel point que madame joëlle
kauffmann la femme de l'un des otages
français a écrit personnellement une
lettre à l'imam commenee convoqué à
l'ambassade d'iran à paris on lui a fait
savoir que son message avait été bien
reçu et que cette démarche n'était pas
inutile
bonsoir
vous donne cette information qui vient
de me parvenir il ya quelques minutes
michel seurat n'a pas été exécutée il
est toujours vivant c'est ce qu'a
déclaré aujourd'hui à beyrouth à notre
confrère de tf1 thierry de scitivaux un
haut responsable du hezbollah le parti
de dieu pro iranien le cheikh salman al
khalil le cheikh al khalil interrogé par
thierry de scitivaux a ajouté sans
autres explications la partie d'hier
jihad islamique le communiqué qui a été
remis hier la partie qui a donné
l'information de l'exécution de l'otage
français est une couverture pour cacher
la faire une couverture pour cacher
d'affaires cheikh al khalil n'a pas été
plus clair mais a affirmé
catégoriquement que michel seurat était
vivant nous allons tenter sur cette
affaire de faire un dossier complet avec
l'ensemble du service de politique
étrangère d'antenne 2 un peu plus de 24
heures après l'annoncé par
l'organisation jihad islamique de
l'exécution du chercheur michel seurat à
beyrouth
rien ne permettait donc jusqu'à ce
communiqué de confirmer la mort de l'un
des quatre otages français
le texte intégral du communiqué de
revendication du jihad islamique et la
photo michel sera jointe ont été
examinés avec attention à beyrouth où se
trouve pour antenne de notre envoyé
spécial philippe rochot on cherchait
tout aujourd'hui à vérifier
l'authenticité encore les rallyes terre
disent qu'on essaie nous annonçons
l'exécution ce qui en arabe s'est
traduit de la même façon que annonçant
qu'il va être exécuté à 0,3
madame seront en premier elle avait
également toujours révéré par la
nouvelle année rencontré plus tôt un
appel au gouvernement français pour des
veaux ciation en tout cas les forces de
sécurité intérieure n'ont découvert
aujourd'hui aucun corps d'étrangers une
date que les rats leader dans les
milieux de dieu à paris la famille de
michel seurat a rappelé qu'il était un
homme de science un chercheur et a tenu
à démentir surtout les accusations
d'espionnage qui étaient portées contre
lui
michel seurat 38 ans né en tunisie selon
ses amis un homme calme doux mais
surtout un grand spécialiste du proche
orient un passionné du monde arabe qui
épouse en 1981 marie une chrétienne
d'origine syrienne dont il aura deux
petites filles habitant vers ou depuis
une dizaine d'années il s'intéresse
particulièrement aux rapports entre les
communautés urbaines et la politique
aujourd'hui
le djihad islamique l'accusent d'avoir
fourni à la france des informations sur
les mouvements islamistes au liban sous
couvert de son travail au cnrs
nous allons travailler à l'étranger
jamais nous ne faisons de ce qu'on
appelle de renseignements c'est
contraire à la déontologie du cnrs nous
ne pouvons pas faire ça sinon c'est
toute notre crédibilité qui disparaît en
revanche c'est que ce que nous faisons
c'est que nous allons nous essayons
contrant nous étudions et ensuite nous
publions ce que nous trouvons ce qu'on
nous a dit tout ce que sera pu dire au
gouvernement français et à tous les
autres gouvernements du monde ça se
trouve dans des revues scientifiques
c'est ça notre travail au cnrs c'était
ça et c'est ça le travail de michel sera
en septembre dernier antenne 2 avait
rencontré marie sera elle attendait
l'ultime coup de téléphone lui annonçant
la libération de son mari hier soir au
moment de l'annoncé du jihad islamique
elle était toujours à beyrouth michel
seurat avait été enlevé le 22 mai de
l'année dernière ainsi que jean-paul
kauffmann deux mois auparavant c'étaient
les diplomates marcel carton et marcel
fontaine
depuis ce temps la france a tenté toutes
les voix officielles possible pour
négocier leur libération
mais il n'y avait pas un seul
interlocuteur et cette prise d'otage
trouvaient ses ramifications dans
plusieurs capitales du proche orient
avec de multiples revendications analyse
de pia sert à ces quatre capitales du
proche et du moyen orient joue le plus
souvent les unes contre les autres
un rôle déterminant sur le sort des
quatre otages français
beyrouth d'abord août où s'exécutent
dans un chaos sanglant
la prise d'otages et quotidienne on les
tient souvent dans la banlieue sud
peuplé de réfugiés souvent miséreux les
factions rivales ici les restes volaille
ne font pas de quartier
beyrouth c'est à la fois le départ le
théâtre est l'aboutissement de toutes
les luttes
il ne faut pas négliger les groupuscules
qui agissent pour leur compte mais ceux
qui tirent les ficelles sont ailleurs à
téhéran notamment où la révolution
islamique bat son plein ces mots d'ordre
ont force de loi
chez les rays bola du liban les pasdaran
les gardiens de la révolution sont eux
aussi directement lié avec les fous de
dieu du liban le contentieux sur les
centrales nucléaires comme celle ci que
devait construire au dif dans le sud de
l'iran est en voie de règlement
l'iran exige en effet que la france
rembourse le prêt 2 milliards $ consenti
par le chat pour ce projet en 1978 mais
les règlements pseudo si que téhéran ne
veut pas lier au sort des otages
intéressement les passes dharan qui
veulent surtout obtenir une libération
des auteurs de l'attentât manqué à paris
contre chapour bakhtiar et qui exigent
comme monnaie d'échangé pour les otages
l'arrêt de l'aide militaire française à
l'irak damas surtout où hafez el assad
le président syrien est au centre de
toutes les manoeuvres diplomatiques et
militaires qui se déroulent dans la
région
il soutient l'iran parce que son
immortel c'est le président irakien
saddam hussein
malgré la présence de son armée hafez
al-assad est pas parvenu jusqu'à présent
à faire libérer nos otages
il a déclaré récemment avoir fait tout
ce qu'il a pu mais il faut croire que
son influence ne parvient pas au liban à
contrebalancer l'influencé de téhéran
sur un ace bola libanais dont les
ravisseurs sont très proches bagdad
enfin en guerre depuis plus de cinq ans
avec l'iran soutenus par les arabes et
par l'occident qui lui livrent des armes
la guerre n'en finit pas la haine grandi
en même temps que le nombre de victimes
qui se comptent par centaines de
milliers saddam hussein le président
irakien n'arrive pas à prendre le dessus
la bavure de l'expulsion par paris de
deux irakiens a créé il ya quelques
jours un nouveau contentieux avec ceux
qui détiennent à beyrouth
nos otages ces deux irakiens avaient été
arrêtés en france la suite des attentats
de ces dernières semaines les services
de police les ont expulsés l'irak corps
est assuré qu'il n'avait pas été exécuté
à leur arrivée c'est aussi ce qu'affirme
l'ambassadeur d'irak à paris rencontrer
parent
fini les deux hommes détenus à bagdad
sont sains et saufs affirme est à
nouveau ce matin l'ambassadeur d'irak
leur sort sera fixé par la justice de
notre pays
ça dépendra le procès et le court et le
jugement
je ne peux pas dire maintenant en avant
avant qu'elles ont l'opportunité d'avoir
tous les faits sur leurs activités et
celles de voile de deux procès du
dissident
l'essor de cette soutien juste une
question est-ce que avant de les
expulser
le gouvernement français vous a demandé
des garanties les concernant nous avons
été informés de l'expansion c'est tout
n'avait pas été contacté avant
l'expulsion
oui nomades contact en avant mais pour
mme en forme et qu'il partait à bagdad
oui rien de plus grande et plus ce soit
encore la question reste posée à ton
expulsé contre leur gré en irak
géraldine et anna faouzi il a été
demandé à la grande bretagne au paraguay
de les recevoir
ces pays ont refusé c'est alors que la
question s'est posée de leur expulsion
dans les conditions juridiques que je
viens de dire est que ressortissant
irakien la police inclus de voir les
expulsés vers leur pays
aucune protestation aucune procédure n'a
été enregistrée la veille même de leur
expulsion
trop tard selon le ministère l'intérieur
les deux hommes avait pourtant rempli
ses demandes de statut de réfugié
politique
il y expliquait que tout retour en irak
signifiait pour eux une condamnation à
mort qu'ils étaient bel et bien opposant
régime de leur propre pays ils n'ont pas
pu vouloir se jeter dans la gueule du
loup insistent les avocats légèreté
bavure coups tordus
force est de constater que les
déclarations officielles ne cadre guère
avec la réalité des faits avec ce qui
s'est passé ici même au dépôt du palais
de justice le 19
riez dernier ce renvoi des deux irakiens
à bagdad faisait partie des reproches
adressés par le djihad islamique à la
france et justifiant selon ce mouvement
l'exécution de l'otage français michel
se rend aujourd'hui aucune information
n'a été livrée pour authentifier ou non
l'annoncé de la mort de michel sera plus
le chef le cheikh al khalili a démenti
avoir affirmé que sera était vivant une
sorte de guerre des nerfs continue donc
et nos envoyés spéciaux philippe rochot
et georges en scène ont rencontré marie
sera aujourd'hui à beyrouth
je ne sais pas à quoi m'en tenir
peut-être qu'il est vivant peut-être
qu'il est mort mais jeudi la compagnie
ya 24 heures je pense que les chances
que michel soit vivant ce sont à 75%
alors après ce démenti
comment interprétez vous la lettre le
communiqué du djihad islamique qui
finalement est maintenant dépassée alors
c'est un moyen de pression
c'était plus qu'un moyen de pression
c'est des menaces et moi personnellement
vivent ici depuis dix ans je sais que ce
sont des menaces qui peuvent être
exécutés
pub les exécuter si ce problème n'est
pas résolu d'une façon ou d'une autre il
y aura une d'équitation de 3 votre avis
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire et
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
maintenant je pense qu'il faudrait
parler aux ravisseurs
le gouvernement a toujours refusé de
parler avec les théories ce temps qui
est parce qu on les connaît pas vraiment
mais on les connaît on sait très diffus
que mouvement mais ce n'est pas dit si
on connaît un deux trois quatre
on les connaît tous ils les connaissent
tous mais il faut qu'il le faible il
faut qu'il faudrait qu'ils aillent bon
peut-être les revendications sont
peut-être impossible du fait qu'on les
garde on égale qu'on les garde six mois
un an mais l'essentiel pour moi
à ce stade là c'est que michel est en
vie gouvernement français après une
réunion interministérielle à matignon a
décidé d'envoyer des émissaires pour
faire avancer les négociations ont le
tout et se vend à edwards lors qu'ils
nous et comment écouter sur le premier
point qui il ne manque pas de
spécialistes en france aussi bien dans
la majorité que dans l'opposition
maintenant ce qui est plus important
c'est de savoir où et pour rencontrer
qui attend une délégation revient à
peine officiellement on en a parlé que
de finances en irak
il n'y a aucune chance que le
gouvernement nous rendent les deux
opposants envoyés sur bagdad
encore faut-il savoir s'ils sont
toujours en vie à damas pour quoi faire
de plus le contact est permanent avec le
président assad depuis des mois sans
résultat concret reste évidemment
beyrouth
et là on se heurte toujours au même
problème avec qui parler
et ce soir pour compliquer le tout un
communiqué du hezbollah qui lie la
sécurité des français au départ de
françois mitterrand
ça n'arrange rien alors la femme de
michel seurat disais tout à l'heure que
l'on avait perdu beaucoup de temps
depuis neuf mois et demi et que l'on a
commis beaucoup d'erreurs cette affaire
effectivement neuf mois et demi c'est
long pour se trouver là on se trouve
aujourd'hui
alors on peut se poser des questions sur
ce qu'on a fait ou ce qu'on n'a pas fait
si le gouvernement français ne s'est pas
trompé de cible en accordant les
négociations comme s'il s'agissait d'un
accord diplomatique en essayant de faire
plaisir à tout le monde
les irakiens les iraniens damas et
surtout et c'est peut-être la plus
grosse erreur en oubliant à qui on a
affaire à des fanatiques
résultat aujourd'hui ils ont renversé la
vapeur ce sont eux qui tiennent entre
leurs mains et les otages et le
gouvernement français
bonsoir après marcel fontaine marcel
carton jean paul kauffmann et michel
seurat depuis hier soir
il faut ajouter à la liste des français
enlevés au liban
les noms de nos amis et camarades de
travail d'antenne de philippe rochot
georges en scène aurel cornéa et jean
louis normandin qu'à 30 de plus prise en
otage et l'on comprendra l'émotion qui
est celle de toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 un correspondant anonyme a
revendiqué ce matin au nom de la djihad
islamique l'enlèvement de l'équipe
d'antenne 2 c'était la dernière
surenchère de ce mouvement contre la
france l'enlèvement a eu lieu en fin
d'après midi hier à beyrouth
voici comment cela s'est passé avec les
explications de françois cornet 7 en
quittant cette mosquée de beer et la
bête dans la banlieue sud de beyrouth où
il avait rejoint son équipe après nous
avoir expédié son reportage que philippe
rochot et ses trois compagnons ont été
pris en filature par la voiture de leurs
ravisseurs
l'équipe d'antenne 2 rejoignait son
hôtel situé sur le port
il était 17 heures à beyrouth après un
kilomètre et demi à la hauteur de la
cité sportive
la voiture qui la suivait et une moto
doublent leur taxi et leur barre la
route
deux hommes armés de kalachnikov monde
dans le taxi et oblige le chauffeur a
continué son chemin en changeant
d'itinéraires quelques rues plus loin
le chauffeur du taxi malmené est obligé
de quitter son véhicule
c'est lui qui fera plus tard le récit de
l'enlèvement depuis aucune nouvelle de
l'équipe d'antenne 2 un confrère ayant
couvert le même reportage à la mosquée
de bir el abed est passé une dizaine de
minutes plus tard sur les lieux
je suis parti avec notre confrère à pied
dans la rue où il y avait toute la foule
qui sortait des femmes voilées et
caetera et rouge les prochains nous
doubler il a fait signe et apparemment
il n'y avait aucun problème
il est évidemment il ya beaucoup de
voitures donc je veux savoir c'est y
suit ou pas nous avons pris un taxi plus
loin ils ont suivi la ultra japon lui
environ
dix minutes plus tard et nous n'avons
rien remarqué de particulier aux
environs de la cité sportive où il
aurait donc été doublée par une
date soul avec des hommes armés et deux
d'entre eux seraient montés dans la
voiture est réel donc on the
mobilisation scellé depuis la nuit
dernière le mot d'ordre des gourmandises
de français présents à beyrouth
les chaises 8 de l'équipe d'antenne 2
hier soir au dîner ont très vite
inquiété
il a fallu plus d'une heure de
recherches pour retrouver le chauffeur
de taxi qui terrorisés se cacher sitôt
les détails de l'enlèvement connu et
deux journalistes et photographes se
sont partagés les téléphones de l'hôtel
cavaliers de l' agence france-presse
pour alerter qui l'ambassade de france
qui des informateurs qu'il est
responsable des milices musulmanes ce
matin après la revendication du jihad
islamique
réunis dans la rédaction de la fp et
jaurès ont décidé d'aller ensemble
devant des décomptes et surtout la
libération de philippe rochot et de son
équipe à moi mes yeux cette femme là le
chef spirituel des mollahs et leurs
chefs politiques l'ibrahim haram ils se
sont crus qui présidait la cérémonie qui
avait couvert les clips antenne 2 avant
d'être enlevé mais abir à la bête comme
à ouzaï passion atterri feuchy est fief
de ces deux responsables les portes sont
restées closes
philippe rochot et son équipe venait
tout juste de réaliser un reportage sur
le parti est ce but-là pro-iranien que
nous diffusions hier soir dans cette
même édition de 20 heures nous avons
choisi de vous leur présentez afin de
mieux comprendre le climat dans lequel
avait à travailler l'équipe d'antenne 2
voilà dans quelle atmosphère bérus vie
la guerre des nerfs dans la bataille des
otages ici les partisans de dieu célèbre
le
1er anniversaire de l'attentât à la
voiture piégée qui avait fait 75 morts
dans ce quartier chic de bir el abed au
sud de beyrouth
juste à côté du domicile du cheikh
fadlallah l'un des chefs religieux les
plus prestigieux du liban c'est pour
cela d'ailleurs que onze suspects ont
été exécutés dernièrement lyall à tous
les dirigeants de ce mouvement qui prend
de plus en plus d'ampleur à beyrouth les
aucun d'eux n'a jamais revendiqué la
responsabilité de l'enlèvement des
otages
leur porte parole le cheikh ibrahim el
amine réaffirme étiez encore qu'il
n'était pour rien dans la sphère est le
sherpa de dallas leur guide spirituel a
toujours condamné ce genre d'action mais
les hommes les chefs de ce mouvement
demeure pourtant les seuls
interlocuteurs auprès des ravisseurs
et c'est ici dans cette mouvance ou
multiples tendances qu'il faut chercher
on comprend que la négociation soit
difficile d'autant qu'à chaque discours
il renvoie la france à ses
responsabilités et pourtant un élément
nouveau jusque là en effet ce mouvement
garder ses distances vis-à-vis de la
syrie empêchant ainsi damas de prendre
une quelconque initiative comme
intermédiaire dans la mer des otages or
aujourd'hui on observe un rapprochement
avec les partis musulmans libanais de
gauche c'est à dire que le hezbollah le
parti de dieu avec nous sommes ici à
aujourd'hui ses entrées à damas qu'il
est accepté or cela peut permettre à la
syrie de peser sur ce parti pour
favoriser une négociation pour une
possible libération des otages français
c'est l'épreuve de force entre le jihad
islamique et le gouvernement français
les intégristes pro-iranien détiennent
maintenant huit personnes en otage pour
notre part paul nahon
nous continuerons notre travail
absolument nous avons en effet décidé
d'envoyer une nouvelle équipe d'antenne
2 à beyrouth
tout simplement pour continuer le
travail d'information commencer par
philippe rochot georges en scène
aurel cornéa les jean louis normandin
c'est notre travail notre devoir et
notre honneur
l'information ne peut pas s'arrêter
c'est dans ces conditions que travailler
l'équipe d'antenne 2 c'est dans ces
mêmes conditions que travailleront
pierre serra patrice du ter et doit
trembler qui part ce soir pour beyrouth
philippe rochot effectué pour antenne 2
une centaine de reportages au liban et
tout le monde là bas toutes tendances
confondues apprécié sa rigueur et son
professionnalisme
nous voulons espérer que l'équipe
d'antenne 2 pourra être libéré très
rapidement les ravisseurs n'ont ils pas
affirmé ce matin que l'équipe était
simplement appréhender et nous ne
voulons pas encore croire qu'elles
soient considérés comme otages quant à
nous nous continuerons un lassabe le
mans a demandé leur libération
immédiatement et sans condition nous
avons utilisé dès hier soir les canaux
officiels
c'est à dire ceux du gouvernement
français mais aussi nos propres
contacter madame monsieur bonsoir
toujours latente à beyrouth la tente
mais aussi une certaine détente le
docteur rade interrompu ce matin ses
négociations avec les ravisseurs qui
détiennent toujours les otages français
c'est apparemment à la fin de la
première phase des discussions avec une
indication une indication de l'émissaire
français
un accord de principe est en voie
d'élaboration mais il reste encore à
régler les détails des détails qui
semblent importants une note optimiste
donc ce soir même si les inconnues
demeurent très nombreuses
nous allons revoir point par point
l'état de la négociation mais d'abord le
film de cette journée à beyrouth avec
notre envoyé spécial ces personnes elles
sont disons encourageants et les deux
choses différentes et le sont toutes
concordantes
aujourd'hui il faut être sur la bonne
voie
les conditions posées par les ravines
so virtuellement dini il reste à les
réaliser
ces dernières 48 heures le docteur a
fait la navette entre beyrouth beaulieu
cdt match pour être au point les bonnets
des pratiques et les garanties d effet
la décision de libérer l'équipe quand
elle a été prise
son sort des paliers à la sphère de
bagdad ditto ici résolution que les
affaires pourraient être pourtant
concomitante
ce qui veut dire que bayrou et ses
coéquipiers devraient être libérés au
plus tard lorsque les irakiens auront
quitté pargade et or ont été reconnus
par ceux qui les réclament
tr ferrat entamé route
vous l'avez entendu optimisme donc
optimisme mesuré sur place mais il faut
rester très prudent l'expérience dans
cette affaire nous l'a appris à de
nombreuses reprises en tout cas il
apparaît à peu près certain ce soir que
le docteur rade à négocier sur deux
points au moins la libération des deux
au projet irakiens expulsés par paris et
le sort du commando qui avait tenté
d'assassiner le premier ministre iranien
à paris le premier ministre chapour
bakhtiar le premier point est actif ce
soir mais le deuxième reste à régler
daniel leconte la remise de de nos
frères irakiens aux autorités irakiennes
alors que la france savait qu'ils
étaient des opposants régime et qu'il
serait exécuté en irak est un défi
dangereux au sentiment de tous les
musulmans
ceci constitue une complicité de crimes
c'est dans ce communiqué annonçant la
mort de michel seurat et publie il y a
une semaine à beyrouth que le djihad
islamique évoqué pour la première fois
la question des deux irakiens expulsés
par paris depuis dans chaque communiqué
publié par la suite leur libération est
devenue la plus urgente des
revendications des ravisseurs
c'est donc maintenant chose faite la
libération d'amanda phase i et d'hassan
géraldine n'est plus qu'une question de
jours sinon d'heures saddam hussein le
président irakien en effet gracié les
deux expulsés fils sont autorisés s'ils
le veulent à retourner en france
un préalable capital pesant sur la
négociation vient donc d'être levée
reste maintenant
l'autre revendication des ravisseurs
elle concerne la libération de cinq
mondes
commando communiste ces cinq hommes
avaient tenté d'assassiner l'ancien
premier ministre iranien chapour
bakhtiar
c'est et en juillet 1981 à neuilly au
cours de la fusillade deux personnes
devaient trouver la mort
arrêté sur le champ quatre d'entre eux
dont le chef du commando anis naccache
été condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
le cinquième à 20 ans rien juridiquement
ne permet de le libérer dans les
prochains jours les cinq hommes n'ont
accompli que six ans de prison
or la peine minimum qu'ils doivent
obligatoirement purgé de 15 ans pour les
en 15 ans pour les uns dix ans pour
l'autre on est donc bien loin du compte
reste donc une seule solution pour
répondre aux ravisseurs la grâce
présidentielle
mesdames messieurs bonsoir un otage
français de plus au liban et une fois
encore c'est un journaliste roger auque
31 ans correspondant de rtl et de la
radio belge à beyrouth
il a été enlevé ce matin tout près de
son domicile dans le secteur ouest de la
capitale
roger auque était l'un des derniers
journalistes français à être restée un
secteur musulman
aucune organisation n'a revendiqué cet
enlèvement pour le moment cela dit
plusieurs témoignages permettent de
reconstituer la façon dont cela s'est
déroulé francine raymond roger auque
quelques minutes avant son enlèvement
avait assisté à une conférence de presse
donnée par l'émissaire de l'archevêque
de canterbury dans un hôtel de
beyrouth-ouest terry wade arrivé hier
dans la capitale libanaise avec l'espoir
d'obtenir de nouvelles libérations
d'otages occidentaux
roger auque faisait partie de ce groupe
de photographes
après la conférence de presse il passera
prendre quelques affaires dans son
appartement un de ses amis journalistes
l'attendait en bas de son immeuble à la
kalach m'a pris par la veste
il m'a dit en anglais suis moi aussi moi
moi j'ai commencé à me débattre et j'ai
vu un projet qui était de l'autre côté
ou de titres donnant le cinéma mais les
olsson immeuble fermé par une grille et
il invite les jeux
vivante et je te rappelle qu'un type qui
a lâché je suis ils sortent un sortant
ne bouge pas on sort pas et il n'a pas
compris si je crois qu'il a pas prouvé
si c'est pas si tu parce que lui il crié
mais qu'est ce qui se passe mais qu'est
ce que vous faites qu'est ce que vous
faites et il est sorti là où l'agrile
essentiellement l'autre type lui a mis
le pistolet sur la tête j'ai vu qui se
débattait aussi par depuis trois ans
roger auque qui était à beyrouth le
correspondant de rtl du journal la croix
et de l' agence gamma
il ne voulait pas quitter le secteur
musulman et ses 10 des assurés par les
récentes libérations d'otages français
ce qui ne l'empêchait pas d'être
conscient du danger de plus en plus on
peut assimiler le métier de reporter à à
celui diplomates des concours de plus en
plus des risques avant d'aller en avait
dix ont l'habitude de chasser d'être
plutôt le chasseur c'était surtout le
reporter mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
on devient un petit peu à gibier son
enlèvement visiblement a été
minutieusement préparé
roger auque est désormais le sixième
français être détenus à nos tâches au
liban
en attendant voici les développements
les autres titres de l'actualité en
commençant par une image symbole image
d'espoir et de paix aussi cet après midi
devant l'ex ambassade d'iran à paris les
proches de marcel carton et de marcel
fontaine deux des otages français au
liban ont témoigné simplement témoignage
émouvant pour dénoncer trois ans de
détention
trois ans de violation des principes
d'humanité les plus élémentaires
philippe gassot pour les trois années
terribles des trois otages français
trois colombes et trois femmes devant
l'ambassade d'iran un geste symbolique
pour que personne n'oublie pas de foules
juste la fille la femme et la soeur tel
attendre
et trois ans et c'est énorme on est venu
ici parce que maintenant le gouvernement
iranien dit qu'il peut nous aider alors
fait ce qu'il peut nous aider qu'il le
fasse vite
les trois ans de douleurs des tristesses
nous qui sommes en liberté c'est dur
pour nous c'est très lourd pour eux je
me demande comment ils vont revenir
après trois ans de captivité les otages
français au liban et tous les autres
n'ont toujours pas été libérés pour le
moment inlassable l'espoir de trois
femmes demeurent les otages français au
liban vont ils se retrouver au coeur
d'une polémique dans la campagne
électorale depuis quelques jours nous
nous posons sérieusement la question il
faut dire que de rumeurs en rumeurs
plusieurs journaux arabes ont évoqué des
coups tordus des basses manoeuvres et
des mensonges autour de la sphère des
otages
hier soir nouveau rebondissement plus
concret celui là un homme d'affaires
syrien qui avait été jusqu'en mars 86
l'un des émissaires de l'elysée dans
cette affaire a fait l'objet d'un arrêté
d'expulsion
on lui reproche notamment d'avoir gêné
par son action la politique du
gouvernement français
voilà sur les faits nous allons y
revenir dans quelques instants beaucoup
plus longuement en attendant on a
l'impression que la sérénité de façade
affiché par françois mitterrand jacques
chirac masques et peut-être d'autres
affrontements en coulisses philippe
gassot l'homme qui a été expulsé c'est
lui omran adam un homme d'affaires
syrien un proche du président hafez
el-assad
il est porteur d'un passeport
diplomatique délivré par damas
cet homme qui vit en france depuis 20
ans vient d'être frappé par une mesure
d'urgence absolue émissaire officieux de
l'élysée en 1985 il a été chargé
d'intervenir dans le processus de
négociations destinées à obtenir la
libération des otages français détenus
au liban dans sa dernière intervention
publique il ya quinze jours
il indique que l'armée syrienne
s'apprêtait à investir le sanctuaire du
hezbollah dans le sud de beyrouth
une information démentie par la syrie
qui précise que monsieur adam ne parle
plus qu en son nom propre
depuis 86 déclare charles pasqua
monsieur rade dame n'a pas servi
d'intermédiaire depuis plus de trois
années que son prisonnier les otages
français au liban rumeurs informations
et contre informations ont été le lot
quasi quotidien
la presse libanaise et de celle des pays
du golfe ce fut à nouveau le cas le 22
avril dernier lorsqu un falcon 50
immatriculé en suisse se pose sur
l'aéroport de beyrouth
on indiqué de sources syriennes que les
otages seront libérés dans les heures
qui viennent pour le cheikh fadlallah
c'est une affaire de quelques jours le
principal négociateur jean charles
marchiani qui représente le ministère de
l'intérieur
rentrer sans les otages la presse
libanaise se déchaînent à le dire un
journal de droite publié à beyrouth est
indique qu'il ya eu promesse de 150
millions de francs et que le hezbollah
aurait demandé dix millions de plus la
voix du liban radio chrétienne sans
citer ses sources parlent de dissension
et de désaccords de dernière minute
apparues au sein du gouvernement
français
un différend qui retarde la libération
le quotidien koweïtien al-qabas
le 29 avril dernier sort à la une sur
deux colonnes un papier qui met en cause
le président français et le diplomate
eric rouleau ce dernier dit al qabas est
intervenu pour empêcher la libération
des otages le lendemain vendredi le
journal koweïtien démord toujours à la
une dimanche al qabas revient à sa
première version
hier un autre journal pro syriens cette
fois de beyrouth indiquent peut être
inspiré par monsieur adam qu'avant mars
86 le rpr a envoyé des émissaires afin
de bloquer les négociations à propos des
otages dans cette partie du monde
les rumeurs deviennent souvent des
informations qui change selon que c'est
l'un ou l'autre qui souffle sur le feu
je propose de revenir quelques minutes
sur le calvaire des otages un calvaire
qui a commencé le 22 mars 85
pour marcel fontaine et marcel carton
marcel carton qui vient d'être libéré et
et le chef du protocole à l'ambassade de
france à beyrouth
marcel fontaine était quant à lui vice
consul de france au liban
l'histoire d'une double prise d'otages
avec martine laroche joubert à vendredi
le 22 mars 1985 au matin on enlève à
beyrouth des diplomates français
le premier vice consul marcel fontaine
est poussé dans une voiture à 300 mètres
à peine de l'ambassade de france dans le
secteur musulman même heure près de la
ligne de démarcation toujours à l'ouest
le chef du protocole marcel carton et sa
fille subisse le même sort
elle est libérée famars pour les deux
otages l'engrenage
par cette lettre le djihad islamique
authentifie sa revendication et menaces
nous terroriseront la france les
familles des diplomates observe le
silence jusqu'à la première
manifestation organisée après
l'enlèvement de jean paul kauffmann
manifestation à laquelle ils sont
associés
de son côté dans l'ombre la femme du
diplomate marcel fontaine effectué des
marches sur démarches auprès des
religieux chiites
peine perdue premier contact avec les
otages
le docteur rade émissaire officieux du
gouvernement promet ses premières
lettres pour les familles et les
précisions
les ravisseurs veulent ta rééquilibrage
la politique française dans le conflit
iran irak et la libération les derniers
libanais détenus en israël le 10
septembre 1985
ces prisonniers libanais du camp dates
limites sont libérés par les autorités
israéliennes
rien ne bouge chez les ravisseurs à 30
ans les familles des otages sont mises
en présence dans le journal d'antenne 2
avec des représentants du mouvement
chiite amal libérateur des otages de la
t2c pouvait les prendre sous son aile et
me promets qu'ils vont être libérés
aussi lorsque monsieur que je suis le
temps passe le 6 octobre 1986 le jihad
islamique
angoisse et de cassettes dix mois plus
tard en août 96 ne recevions c'est le
casse-tête de marcel carton
c'était ces dernières nouvelles avant sa
libération et celle de marcel son plein
notre confrère notre confrère jean paul
kauffmann qui vient d'être libéré à 43
ans il a été pris en otage le 22 mai
1985 je vous rappelle que jean paul
kauffmann et est envoyé comme grand
reporter au liban pour l'événement du
jeudi son enlèvement avait été
revendiqué dès le 29 mai 85 par le
djihad islamique 22 1985 c'est sur la
route de l'aéroport de beyrouth en plein
combat entre chiites et palestiniens que
jean paul kauffmann et michel seurat
sont enlevés dix jours plus tard
revendications du jihad islamique
il réclame la libération des 17
terroristes prisonniers au koweït pour
relâcher le chercheur michel seurat et
le journaliste jean paul kauffmann les
amis de jean paul kauffmann décide de
porter la faire sur la place
lyc ils organisent les manifestations
auxquelles sont associées les diplomates
marcel carton et marcel fontaine enlevé
deux mois plus tôt le comité kaufmann
reçoit des lettres par milliers organisé
l'exposition de dessins d'enfants sur le
thème de la liberté et multiplie les
interventions
joëlle kauffmann choisi la stratégie de
l'action 12 juin dans un beyrouth chaque
jour plus déchiré joëlle kauffmann donc
d'arracher quelques informations aux
dignitaires religieux des cartouches y
le girad réclament maintenant la
libération du commando qui a tenté
d'assassiner chapour bakhtiar l'ancien
premier ministre iranien
à cette époque le mot-clé la situation
paraît être nabih berry le chef du
groupe amal l'homme qui a fait libérer
les passagers de la twh et pour les
otages français
c'est la puissance 13 mars 1986 l'équipe
d'antenne 2 vient d'être enlevé michel
sera peut être assassiné des milliers de
personnes écoutent avec émotion l'appel
de joëlle kauffmann savez ce que vous
venez de faire ne peut que vous
discréditer et disent que d'idées votre
compte aux yeux du peuple français de
tout vos amis je vous en supplie arrêté
22 mai une manifestation de plus
silencieuse
cela fait exactement un homme jean paul
kauffmann a été enlevé le 21 juin
joëlle kauffmann bouleversé assiste à
l'arrivée à paris de philippe rochot et
jan janssen libéré travail et être plus
de trois mois après le djihad islamique
envoie une cassette du jean paul
kauffmann amaigri mais la voix ferme
nous sommes pas dit il des intérêts
supérieurs aux 87 dernier message de
jean paul kauffmann c'est avec la même
joie et la même retenue que françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac ont salué
ce soir la libération des trois otages
français du liban dans une intervention
télévisée en direct de l'elysée le chef
de l'état a remercié tous ceux qui ont
permis aujourd'hui la photo mesdames et
messieurs la libération de messieurs
marcel carton marcel fontaine et jean
paul kauffmann me remplit de joie
au nom du pays tout entier
j'exprime à nos trois compatriotes ainsi
qu'à leurs familles d'une part notre
soulagement les voir revenir parmi nous
à leurs familles la compassion que nous
inspire une si longue épreuve je suis
heureux que les efforts entrepris depuis
le début de ce drame est enfin abouti et
je remercie tous ceux qui ont oeuvré
pour ce retour nous aurons aussi une
pensée pour celui qui n'est pas revenu
michel seurat et pour les siens ainsi
que pour les otages étrangers en porc
retenu au libre
en attendant
libération des trois derniers otages
français au liban les images se
bousculent dans nos têtes et dans nos
esprits nous sommes témoins de grands
moments de joie d'émotion
d'interrogation aussi nous y reviendrons
ce sont ces images que nous allons
privilégier dans un premier temps
ensuite nous essaierons de comprendre
pourquoi et comment on en est arrivé là
en toile de fond il aura des témoignages
l'historique des négociations nous
évoquerons également le rôle joué par
certains états dans ce genre d'affaires
mais tout de suite l'image symbole de
cette journée celle que nous avons
enregistré ce matin sur l'aéroport de
villacoublay
les retrouvailles sont extrêmement
dignes fallait dire discrète
seuls les enfants ont laissé poindre
leur émotion philippe gassot à son
arrivée jean paul kauffmann à une
hésitation une fraction de seconde il ne
reconnaît pas son fils grégoire et trois
ans c'est une éternité pour un enfant
quand son père est parti en reportage au
liban il avait 11 ans aujourd'hui dans à
14 les retrouvailles ont été très digne
presque trop comme si des amis se
retrouvaient après une longue absence la
gêne peut être d'avoir changé pays et de
n'avoir plus qu'un passé lointain en
commun seuls les enfants qui ont pendant
trois ans révélée retrouvailles l'espace
et leur trop plein de chagrin
ce sont trois années de l'armée d'angoua
ce qui passe la bonde il va falloir du
temps pour se reconnaître
mais c'est fait les familles sont à
nouveau réunis les journalistes eux
retrouvent un des leurs enlevés sur la
route de l'aéroport à berrer il bosse et
dans toutes les pensées mais oui nous a
dit cela c'est un jour formidable bien
sûr aujourd'hui mais
c'est quand même un jour qui qui est qui
qui reste assombri par le fait que nous
ne sommes que trois et que moi j'ai été
enlevé le 22 mai 1985 avec un homme qui
s'appelait michel seurat gg j'étais avec
lui pendant de longs mois et puis nous
l'avons vu s'éteindre peu à peu et gg
d'une certaine manière j'ai un peu honte
aujourd'hui la d'être la fab on ne
jouons pas sur les mots mais c'est sa
demande et un marcel carton et marcel
fontaine on a vu michel seurat lutter
avec avec avec eux avec des espaces il
ya aussi j'veux dire avec avec avec
noblesse l'aï ils ne s'exprimaient pas
beaucoup il se voyait mourir il a voulu
vivre ccc c'est quelque chose d'affreux
et puis aujourd'hui d'abord et avant
tout ma pensée va à marie sera sa femme
je ne sais pas où elle est actuellement
mais et à ses deux filles
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
avec désespoir il ya aussi j'veux dire
avec avec avec noblesse là ils
s'exprimaient pas beaucoup il se voyait
mourir il a voulu vivre ccc c'est
quelque chose de d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
michel
au début me disait tu sais moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal personnellement au début
les premières semaines furent furent
affreuse
michel lui était tout à fait bon il
prenait la situation avec une certaine
philosophie prenait des notes il
écrivait cetera
et puis enfin il disait moi tu sais je
suis prêt à attendre trois ans pour
revoir mes deux filles j'ai mis trois
ans mais je suis mais tu es fou tu te
rends compte trois ans et puis bon et
c'est le meilleur qui a disparu nous
l'avons vu pour la dernière fois le 28
décembre 1985 n'était n'arrivait plus à
tenir debout il a été transféré dans un
endroit côté de nos deux de nos cellules
de notre cellule
et puis on l'a entendu pendant encore
quelques jours
aytus effroyablement il avait faut
passer ccc c'est quelque chose de
terrible
on était tous les quatre ensemble
mais on va demander à marcel carton à
marcel fontaine là ils ont vus
quotidiennement là et qui lui tape il
savait qu'il a failli c'est parce qu'il
avait exactement mais ils savaient
qu'ils allaient que c'était quick
c'était désespère il aurait pu
et moi je prends fait il aurait pu
mourir auprès des siens et puis il est
mort tout seul c'est quelque chose
d'affreux ça je ne peux pas l'oublier en
question oui nous étions enchaîné depuis
le mois de février l'an dernier après
les là l'intervention fin ce week-end
les les bateaux là qui s'approchait des
côtes
ç'a eu pour résultat qu'on ne supprime
la radio premièrement et ensuite qu'on
nous pose des chaînes et puis bon on a
eu des mois j'ai eu les chaînes aux
pieds 7 mai compagnon depuis le mois de
février
l'an dernier bon on s'y habitue 1 on
revient pas de des camps de la mort il
faut pas exagérer non plus mais c'est ça
a été on en a survécu voilà revenons à
la libération des trois derniers otages
français au liban l'histoire retiendra
que cette libération est intervenue le 4
mai 88 à quelques jours seulement de
l'élection présidentielle l'histoire qui
est jalonnée de dates retiendra
également qu'il aura fallu plus de trois
ans et oui plus de trois ans pour
libérer les otages français
martine laroche joubert 22 mars 1985
marcel carton et marcel fontaine sont
enlevés à beyrouth-ouest par le jihad
islamique organisation intégriste pro
iranienne qui exigent l'arrêt du soutien
français à l'irak
le lendemain 22 mars c'est au tour de
gilles pérol directeur du centre
culturel de tripoli retenu par les farl
des chrétiens marxiste qui le relâche le
2 avril en échange semble-t-il de la
libération d'abdallah toujours
emprisonnés en france 22 mai sur la
route de l'aéroport enlèvement de jean
paul kauffmann et du chercheur michel
seurat les ravisseurs le djihad
islamique encore leurs exigences la
libération du commando chapour bakhtiar
près d'un an après le 5 mars 86 le
djihad islamique annonce l'exécution de
michel seurat d'après jean paul
kauffmann il serait mort d'un cancer
trois jours après la mort annoncée de
michel sera le 8 mars 86 l'équipe
d'antenne 2 et enlever par le jr
l'organisation de la justice
révolutionnaire de mouvance iranienne
qui dénonce l'ensemble de la politique
française au proche orient le 20 juin
philippe rochot et jan janssen sont
libérés le 24 décembre c'est au tour
d'oreille cornea tandis que jean louis
normandin restent emprisonnés la même
année 86 deux autres français sont
libérés camille sont à 2 84 ans et
marcel khoudary mais le 13 janvier 87
l'histoire recommence projet aux
journalistes est enlevée il sera libéré
le 27 novembre 87 par le jr en même
temps que jean louis normandin d'antenne
2 il n'y a plus aujourd'hui d'otages
français aux mains d'extrémistes
libanais certaine libération d'otages
aurait sans doute pu se dérouler et
intervenir beaucoup plus tôt mais il
faut savoir que des contentieux
politiques
militaire également des contentieux
financiers ont souvent bloqué l'issue
des négociations
à ces blocages se sont également ajoutés
des actes de terrorisme qui ont fait
malheureusement monter la pression
explications de jean marc qui louent au
coeur du contentieux franco-iranien il
ya d'abord une guerre celle que se
livrent depuis huit ans l'irak et l'iran
plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts
et de blessés or la france après l'urss
et le deuxième fournisseur d'armes de
l'irak
facturé en milliards de francs miracle
missiles hélicoptères et surtout des
systèmes de guidage électronique
terriblement efficace après avoir
d'abord exigé sans succès la suspension
pure et simple de l'aide française à
l'irak l'iran et les groupes terroristes
qui le soutiennent réclameront une
politique plus équilibrée
en clair de pouvoir acheter les mêmes
armes que leurs ennemis irakien la
france a toujours dit non mais à paris
comme ailleurs
aucun gouvernement n'échappera aux
accusations de vente clandestine d'armes
à l'iran deuxième source de conflit la
présence en france d'opposants iraniens
condamnés par le régime de téhéran
asile politique pour l'ancien chef de
gouvernement bani sadr en 81 et surtout
pour massoud radjavi chef des
moudjahidines du peuple
son expulsion en juin 86 permettra la
libération de philippe rochot georges en
scène l'expulsion de ses partisans en
décembre 87 sera un nouveau signe de la
poursuite des interminables tractations
entre paris et téhéran
troisième source de conflits les actes
terroristes monte à téhéran cinq
terroristes emprisonnés en france après
un attentat sanglant juillet 80 ne
seront jamais libéré mais en novembre 87
wahid gordji numéro deux de l'ambassade
d'iran suspects de complicité dans les
attentats qui firent 11 morts et 150
blessés en plein paris en septembre 86
sera soudain lavé de tout soupçon son
départ de paris mettra fin à quatre mois
de guerre des ambassades et surtout
surviendra deux jours à peine après la
libération de roger auque et jean louis
normandin le 25 mars 88
nouveau coup de théâtre mohamed mourad
gère un français d'origine libanaise
également soupçonné dans les mêmes
attentats de septembre 86 sera à son
tour
libéré après un an de détention
libération interprété comme un signal de
paris aux iraniens et à leurs partisans
libanais quatrième contentieux le
contentieux financier
d'un côté la dette d'un milliard de
dollars contracté par la france aux
temps du shah d'iran
de l'autre les intérêts des firmes
françaises les et pendant la révolution
islamique
deux tiers de ces dettes remboursées par
la france en 86 peut être un troisième
demain si un accord existe enfin sur le
montant des intérêts payables par paris
pour marcel fontaine marcel carton et
jean paul kauffmann et pour tous ceux
qui négocier leur libération la dernière
ligne droite a été jalonné d'échecs et
aussi de rebondissements retentissant
souvenez vous par exemple du
détournement d'avion déco et r'ways le
détournement est intervenue au moment
précis où l'on télé pratiquement pour
acquise la libération des otages hervé
brusini la crau l'imprévu le voilà ce
boeing déco et airlines immobilisé sur
l'aéroport d'alger
c'était à la mi avril une trentaine de
passagers et un commando qui réclame la
libération de dix sept extrémistes
chiites détenus au koweit
la mécanique de la négociation sur les
otages français est bloqué ceux qui
tiennent cet avion appartiennent à la
même mouvance que les ravisseurs de
cartons fontaine et kaufman 20 avril la
médiation algérienne dénoue la crise et
deux jours plus tard un falcon 50 se
pose sur l'aéroport de larnaca à son
bord les émissaires français parmi eux
jean charles marchiani
voici la seule image de cet homme de
l'ombre ce businessman ancien lieutenant
du contre espionnage français au passé
tumultueux il était en liaison
permanente avec charles pasqua lors
conversation téléphonique se faisait en
langue corse
mais ce jour là le voyage de retour a eu
lieu sans les otages
un revirement koweïtien dans des
promesses faites sur l'allègement des
peines des 17 détenus en est peut être
la raison
autre homme clé du dossier otages
iskandar safa chrétiens libanais homme
d'affaires ami du président syrien
il serait l'un des banquiers de l'iran à
beyrouth peut-être est-ce là ni salué
par jacques chirac dans sa déclaration
et quiches et le nombre d'actions
employés nous en parler un tout petit
peu non
je sais bien il était bien dans cette
affaire simplement sans crois que
j'avais assez dit c'est un ami de la
france comme au groupe beaucoup de
chrétiens libanais alors disons pour
fournir que leur seconde patrie y est la
france et ils font pas fort pour la
france des choses que d'autres ne font
pas eh bien écoutez je pense que vous
avez presque tout dit je dirais
simplement que je n'ai pas dit qu'il
s'agissait de lui
vous avez entamé à fait j'ai simplement
dit qu'elles étaient ses qualités mais
je ne sais pas si c'est un ami de l'iran
l'algérie on sait a également facilité
pour des raisons humanitaires le
règlement des dernières opérations de
cette libération
mais ce qui a provoqué l'accélération du
dénouement reste encore pour l'instant
une énigme
paul kauffmann raconte il s'est adressé
ce matin à ses confrères et par leur
intermédiaire donc à vous pour vous dire
un peu de ce qu'il a vécu pendant trois
ans alors qu'à l'origine il arrivait à
beyrouth pour un reportage pour
l'événement du jeudi plusieurs moments
très émouvants au cours de cette
conférence de presse jean paul kauffmann
était visiblement très éprouvé il venait
de rencontrer marie sera la femme de
l'otage français morts à beyrouth
jérôme baugnies moments les plus les
plus durs les plus élevés de ces
détentions là on sentait physiquement là
la mort là qui met vraiment mimiques
hydrojets là autour de nous la la comme
un chien latente qui vous guide qui
renifle épi qui s'en va qui revient et
cetera c'était il y avait une présence
physique qui était terrible et qui lui
gardait le silence wendel pareil il
n'avait pas envie de parler
visiblement fatigué jean paul kauffmann
était très ému par l'entrevue qu'il
venait d'avoir juste avant cette
conférence de presse avec marie sera
l'épousé de michel sorin après de longs
remerciements à son comité de soutien
ainsi qu'à jacques chirac et charles
pasqua
kaufman a refusé pour des raisons de
sécurité de donner trop de précisions
sur les autres otages actuellement
détenu à beyrouth
est ce que vous pourriez essayer de nous
expliquer ce qui au fond de vous-même
vous a permis de tenir le coup
physiquement et moralement pendant ces
trois années d'une détention
particulièrement pénible va mal de
choses qui m'ont permis de détenir bon
bon j'ai ggg bon dieu dieu bon jeu ne
nous étions pas perdu de vue mais bon
j'étais bon je sais pas comment vous
expliquez cc c'est vrai que c'est
difficile
cc c'est difficile c'est difficile à
dire a expliqué mais bon et c'est vrai
que c'est un peu le piètre alors aussi
de re découvrir dieu aidant dans des
circonstances on est dans le malheur
bombard en ce sens va en prix et puis on
se tourne vers dieu là il fallait sans
doute que ce soit fait dans des
circonstances piètre m dans ce malheur
oui c'est dieu et la bible bon moment
beaucoup pds étaient très curieux
d'ailleurs parce que bon dans les livres
lesquels les lie au jésus a certainement
pas mal de livres
et puis on y les perdais tout le temps
dans nos 18 déménagement on les
retrouvait plus des ces gares etc
mais la bible elle suivait tout le temps
donc il ya dieu sait et c'est très clair
puis il ya eu les livres les livres qui
m'ont permis de survivre la littérature
ou la littérature
ça m'a permis de survivre pour moi j'ai
vécu par exemple la voyez j'ai le tome 2
devant ça fait un peu spectaculaire il
montre deuxième volume de tolstoï la
gare à fait je fais de la publicité pour
bon et ce livre là ne m'a pratiquement
jamais quitté et il est le deuxième tome
a juste eu lieu à porter deuxième sommet
ce que le premier nous l'avions il a été
égaré ça posait un problème d'ailleurs
parce que marcel carton est bon et il
n'avait pas le premier à la rue d'ulm dû
raconter le premier je sais pas si vous
avez lu guerre et paix mais simplement
dit et alors j'ai passé quand même
plusieurs jours a été suspecté bon tu
vois natacha le prince andré des mariés
avant et cetera est bon alors ce livre
là et puis d'ailleurs il était beaucoup
plus volumineux parce qu'il a été
tellement les pages ont tellement été
tournée et puis lithaire file avait une
très curieuse forme et il avait le
double d'ailleurs de ce2 de cette
épaisseur là il a dit les ponts avec
saab ont voyez par exemple ce texte là
là moi ça m'a toujours temps quand le
prince andré parle de la mort
il va mourir le pressent driss et diesse
vraiment la mort se dit le prince andré
en considérant d'un regard neuf ans
vieux l'herbe c'est la veille de ces
pendant la bataille de borodino l'air
l'armoise et le filet de fumée qui
s'élevait de la balle noir
tourbillonnantes et le pass andré dit je
ne peux pas je ne veux pas mourir
j'aime la vie j'aime cette herbe cette
terre et l'air de ça ça me faisait
pleurer
jean charles marchiani c'est l'homme de
l'ombre de charles pasqua ancien agent
secret devenu conseiller ministériel
puis préfet de la république
c'est un personnage très controversé
sulfureux pour les uns mais pour
d'autres un homme providentiel c'est lui
qui avait obtenu la libération des
otages français du liban en 1988
caroline since yvon godin pour roger
auque journaliste indépendant sur les
terrains de guerre jean charles
marchiani est avant tout l'homme qui l'a
sauvée des griffes du hezbollah libanais
c'était en novembre 87 les otages roger
auque et jean louis normandin d'antenne
2 sont libérés après un an et deux ans
de captivité
dans les minutes qui ont suivi ma
libération à beyrouth je suis tombé nez
à nez dans une des voitures blindées de
l'ambassade de france
avec ce personnage ans charles jean
charles marchiani qui s'est présenté
tout de suite en me disant qu'il était
l'envoyé spécial de charles pasqua et
que c'était lui qui négocier la
libération des otages français au liban
cinq mois plus tard les trois derniers
otages français au liban sont à leur
tour relâché par le hezbollah
après trois ans d'intenses négociations
mission réussie grâce aux méthodes
marquer maintenant ses membres savent et
se créent n'hésitez pas à apprendre des
risques muel risqué sa vie en allant
dans la banlieue sud de beyrouth en
allant des dossiers directement avec les
islamistes du hezb aulas pour essayer
d'avoir des informations sur les otages
et pour renégocier notre libération un
autre homme de l'ombre à contribuer à
ces libérations
iskandar safa influent homme d'affaires
libanais il a versé 9 millions d'euros à
jean charles marchiani
hier le juge courroye a interrogé
marchiani sur ces commissions occultes
que récompenses telles le juge soupçonne
marchiani d'avoir été grassement payés
pour services rendus dont les dossiers
qui le rattrape aujourd'hui c'est
surtout le milieu des marchands d'armes
et ce qu'on appelle les intermédiaires
qui sont ces réseaux jean charles
marchiani rencontré au milieu des années
iskandar safa qui est l'héritier d'une
grande famille libanaise spécialisée
dans le commerce international des
grands marchés des arts mais pas
seulement
et mme arkani est devenu intermédiaire
avec iskandar safa dans toute une série
de marchés et y compris la vente d'armes
au moyen-orient la justice en fait va
lancer un mandat d'arrêt international
contre iskandar safa
jean charles marchiani agent secret
homme d'affaires puis préfet de la
république et enfin un homme politique a
toujours été le plus fidèle lieutenant
de charles pasqua
derrière lui c'est tout un système de
liaisons dangereuses et de financement
douteux qui pourraient être mis à jour
charles pasqua est lui aussi dans le
collimateur
[Musique]